oh
[Musique]
chalon les aventures des aventures
allons vous conter l'histoire des
aventures
de naboo
ce jour là la fin d'ailleurs des
habitants
vertou ma de brand
voici dans ce pays
là
[Musique]
où
en
[Musique]
regardons là au milieu de la route
je ne me prend pas c'est un blaireau
ou à goop il
descendons
avant qu'il ne nous échappe
[Musique]
et il le fera plus de mal
nous n'avions pas besoin de nous presser
jolie police qui vont bien quatre livres
les regarde donc cette gorge fourni moi
je dirai au moins 100 livres
[Musique]
bonne journée déjà la pêche avaient été
excellentes qui ne voudra pas tardé à
préparer cette belle fourrure cause
toujours mon baume même poney pointe
encore prête à sécher
[Musique]
m
goupil goupil en groupe ils ont gobé
[Musique]